Trump's UN General Assembly speech this
year contains some old material not long
ago Venezuela was one of the richest
countries on earth today socialism has
bankrupted the oil-rich nation virtually
everywhere socialism or communism has
been tried it has produced suffering
corruption and decay all nations of the
world should resist socialism and the
misery that it brings to everyone Trump
said roughly the same thing in last
year's UN speech and he got a similar
awkward response the problem in
Venezuela
is not that socialism has been poorly
implemented but that socialism has been
faithfully implemented Trump doesn't
seem to realize that the Cold War is
over and the specter of Soviet style
Marxism Leninism is no longer hanging
over Eastern Europe meanwhile Trump also
doesn't seem to realize that socialism
is rather popular around the world the
German Social Democratic Party the
British Labour Party many political
organizations and leaders across the
world adhere to some vague form of
socialism in fact socialism is getting
more popular in places that are a lot
closer to Washington than Venezuela
[Music]
we believe that every working-class
American deserves the opportunity to
change their economic destiny and their
children's future that is well that's
the message that we need to bring into
the midterms
[Music]
facing head-on this crisis in our
democracy where people feel like the
same laws don't apply to rich
[Music]
hen and we should absolutely have a
healthcare system that provides health
care so every citizen in our country
socialism is quite popular among
Millennials in the United States more
popular than capitalism in fact some
pollsters say that if Donald Trump had
run against Bernie Sanders in the 2016
presidential election he might not have
been able to pull off his victory we
decided to ask Dakota Lilly a young
activist why he thinks that socialism is
on the rise in the United States people
my age especially they're really sick of
you know bills that capitalism brings
upon if you look at the student loan
crisis right now student loan debt is
the largest holder of debt in the
country more than credit card debt you
know we have for-profit you know
educational institutions that charge
sixty seventy eighty thousand dollars
per semester per year you know the
unemployment rate Trump says it's 4% or
3% in actuality it's eight nine ten
percent third half the room is made up
of socialists you know it's made up of
people from Bolivia and Cuba Venezuela
China you know and go South Africa it's
made up of people who completely
disagree with him on that and you know
if you look at last year's speech he
said you know socialism in Venezuela is
not failing because it's being you know
put to use wrongly it's being put to use
completely correctly no one said
anything for a good solid five seconds
and then this year they laughed at him
actually
so when Trump repeated his
anti-socialist tirade at the UN the
question is was he really aiming at
Caracas or was he aiming at a new source
of opposition to his policies here at
home where it seems that Trump has
unwittingly made socialism great again
Kalib Maupin RT New York
you